كم عدد الحالات التي تعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة
ستصل إلى مليون حالة إلى 10 ملايين
حالة أو هذه نحن أو ليس
لدينا أي فكرة تعرفها ، جيك كن صادقًا
معك لنكون صادقًا معك ، ليس لدينا حقًا
أي فكرة مؤكدة هناك  أشياء تسمى
النماذج وعندما ينشئ شخص ما نموذجًا ،
فإنه يضع افتراضات مختلفة ويكون
النموذج جيدًا ودقيقًا فقط
مثل افتراضاتك وكلما
ظهرت النماذج ، فإنها تقدم سيناريو أسوأ
حالة وأفضل
سيناريو بشكل عام  في مكان ما
في الوسط ، لم أر أبدًا
نموذجًا للأمراض التي تعاملت معها والتي
ظهر فيها أسوأ سيناريو في الواقع ،
فإنها دائمًا ما تتخطى حدودها ، لذا عندما
تستخدم أرقامًا مثل مليون
ونصف مليون ونصف المليون ، فمن المؤكد تقريبًا
أنها  خارج الرسم البياني الآن ، هذا ليس مستحيلًا
ولكنه غير محتمل جدًا ، لذا من
الصعب تقديمه ، أعني بالنظر إلى ما
نراه الآن ، تعلمون أنني سأقول ما بين
100 و 200 ألف حالة ولكني لا
أريد التمسك بذلك لأنه
هو - هي  إنها عذرًا للوفيات ، أعني أنه
سيكون لدينا ملايين الحالات ولكني
لا أعتقد أننا بحاجة حقًا إلى
عمل إسقاط عندما يكون هدفًا متحركًا
بحيث يمكنك بسهولة أن تكون
مخطئًا وتضلل الناس بما نفعله  أعلم أن جيك
هو أننا واجهنا مشكلة خطيرة في
نيويورك ، لدينا مشكلة خطيرة في نيو
أورلينز وسنعمل على تطوير
مشاكل خطيرة في مناطق أخرى ، لذا
على الرغم من أن الناس يحبون تصميمها ،
فلنلقِ نظرة على بيانات ما لدينا
و  لا تقلق بشأن هذه السيناريوهات الأسوأ والأكثر حالة
، فأنا متأكد من أن moco PEZ داخل مركز Javits
في مانهاتن حيث
أنشأ المسؤولون هذا المستشفى الميداني الذي
ترى فيه أغطية أسرة عناصر أخرى داخل
هذه الغرف لديك مصنع يوجد به
مطهر لليدين
و  كان هذا في جميع أنحاء القاعة هنا في
جميع أنحاء مركز المؤتمرات هذا ،
يوجد الكثير من خطوط مركز المؤتمرات هذا على بعد
ستة مبانٍ حول مانهاتن في جميع
أنحاء القاعات هنا يمكنك أن ترى
هنا أقسامًا أخرى تم
تحويلها إلى غرف FEM  بناء هذا مع
عمال البناء العسكريين هنا
ثم داخل هذه الغرف ، هناك
أيضًا أكياس برتقالية سيتم
إعطاؤها للمهنيين الطبيين
وداخل الكثير من هذه الحقائب
ستجد في أي منشأة طبية
هناك مقص شاش  الفوط
الصحية هناك معقم لليدين
، حتى أن هناك معدات سيستخدمها الأطباء
بشريط شاش لسماعة الطبيب
أشياء أخرى هنا حتى يتمكن الممرضون
والأطباء من حماية أنفسهم عندما
يبدؤون في علاج المرضى هنا ، وهناك
أيضًا عسل
أعطوه بعض هؤلاء المرضى.
عندما يأتون إلى
غرفهم لمحاولة منحهم بعض
الراحة وما يمرون به
هناك مرطب للشفاه ثم هناك عسل
يصنعه مركز جاكوب جافيتس على سطحهم بنفسه على
أمل أن يتم افتتاحه الأسبوع المقبل  يقول الحاكم
إنه يريد أربعة مواقع أخرى مثل
هذه في جميع أنحاء المدينة عبر مدينة نيويورك
في كل منطقة من برونكس إلى
جزيرة ستاتن.
سيوافق الرئيس على بعض
المساعدة الإضافية حتى يتمكنوا من فتح تلك
المواقع لمحاولة تخفيف الضغط
عن الكثير من المستشفيات التي
تواجه عددًا هائلاً من المرضى أثناء
محاولتهم التعامل مع الفيروس
وانتشاره في جميع أنحاء هذه المدينة و  الولاية ، لذلك
نأمل أن يتم فتح هذا الأسبوع المقبل ،
وبعد ذلك سيكون هناك المزيد من الأماكن مثل هذه
التي تم إنشاؤها عبر نيويورك
في أرلينغتون فيرجينيا ، حيث يقترب فني محمي جيدًا من
سيارة في
موقع اختبار فيروس كورونا من خلال القيادة يعطي
تعليمات حول
بوق للمريض في  على الجانب الآخر من
النافذة المغلقة ، يسحب المريض
بعد ذلك المبنى إلى نقطة تفتيش
أخرى للحصول على المسؤولين المختبرين في
مركز مستشفى فرجينيا الذي يدير هذا المرفق
ويقولون إنهم يجرون حوالي 50 إلى 60 اختبارًا
يوميًا ملايين الأشخاص في الولايات
المتحدة وحولها  يطرح العالم
أسئلة مهمة حول إجراء الاختبار
للبدء في كيفية معرفة ما إذا كنت بحاجة إلى
اختبار فيروس كورونا يؤدي إلى السعال
وضيق التنفس ،
إذا كان لديك مؤشر قوي على
أنك بحاجة إلى اختبار ،
فمن يجب عليك الاتصال بالمسؤولين الأوائل ، ويقول إنه
لا تحضر المكالمة مسبقًا ، فأنت تقوم
أولاً بإخطار طبيب الأسرة الخاص بك
وسوف يقوم الطبيب بإجراء فحص لمعرفة ما إذا
كنت تفي بالمعايير المراد اختبارها.
لا نريد اختبار الأفراد بشكل جيد بمجرد
قيام الأطباء بتقييمك ،
سيحدد ما إذا كنت بحاجة إلى
ترتيبها وسيكتبون هذا الأمر ،
ثم تتصل بخط الجدولة وتحدد
موعدًا في هذا المرفق في
أرلينغتون عند وصول المرضى  يحتاجون
إلى الحفاظ على نوافذ سياراتهم حتى يحين
وقت الاختبار هنا ، حيث يستغرق الاختبار
حوالي 10 دقائق ويتم
إعادة النتائج في غضون خمسة إلى سبعة أيام ،
لكن العديد من مواقع الاختبار عن بُعد تتعرض
لضغوط أكبر من تلك الموجودة في بعض
المناطق مثل مدينة نيويورك
انخفاض مستوى الأقنعة والعباءات
إلى حد أنهم يريدون قصر الاختبار على أولئك الذين
تعرضوا لأضرار بالغة ، حيث يتم إدخالهم إلى المستشفى في كل اختبار
نقوم بإجرائه يأخذ
معدات حماية شخصية قيّمة يمكن استخدامها
عندما نكون  بالنسبة لأولئك الموجودين
في المستشفى
، تعطي وزارة الصحة والخدمات البشرية الأولوية
لاختبارات فيروس كورونا ، المرضى الذين دخلوا بالفعل في
المستشفى مع
أعراض كبار السن الذين تزيد أعمارهم عن 65 عامًا
والذين يعانون من ضعف في
جهاز المناعة والحالات الكامنة
مع الأعراض إذا أجريت الاختبار ،
على استعداد لبعض الانزعاج في
منشأة أرلينغتون ، يقومون بإدخال مسحة
في مؤخرة الحلق ، ولكن الأمر مختلف ، حيث
كان الاختبار سريعًا للغاية ولكنه يصل إلى حد معقول
في جيوبك الأنفية ، وليس من
المريح لموظف التمريض الذي تحدثنا
إليه في موقع أرلينغتون  تناولنا
الأسباب الحاسمة الأخرى التي أقودها
وأنا أقودها ومواقع اختبار أخرى عن بُعد
، نحاول
منع الرحلات غير الضرورية إلى
قسم الطوارئ لدينا للأفراد الذين
يسعون إلى هذا الاختبار ، لذلك
نمنحهم الوسائل للقيام بذلك ثانيًا ،
كما أنه يوفر  الكثير من معدات الحماية الشخصية
للقيام بذلك بهذه الطريقة
سؤال آخر شائع يتعلق بأماكن
مثل هذه  هل يمكن اختبار أكثر من شخص واحد
في السيارة ، يقول الأشخاص الذين يديرون هذا
المرفق إنه يمكن اختبار أي شخص في السيارة
طالما كان لديه
موعد وقد تمت إحالته إلى
هذا المكان من قبل طبيبه بقدر
ما هو هذا المكان
سيظل الأشخاص الذين يديرون هذا المرفق مفتوحين يقولون ما
دام لديهم
معدات الحماية الشخصية التي
يحتاجها العمال هنا
، أعني كل من يعتقد أن الناس
سيكونون مرتاحين لصب قلوبهم في
الصباح وهذا هو اعترافنا في
الواقع هذا هو المكان الذي نرغب فيه  كنا
نأتي إلى هنا للاعتراف ، لكن
هذا غير ممكن الآن ،
لذلك قلنا إننا نحضره في الهواء الطلق ،
لقد حاولت الاعتراف أثناء الصوم الكبير
بفيروس كورونا الذي تعرفه ، وأغلق
كل شيء واكتشفت جيدًا أن
هذا لن يحدث هذا العام.  أعتقد
أنه من الرائع أن يجعلوا هذا
متاحًا للناس وكان من
المهم أن يعرف الناس مدى
حب كاهنهم لهم والاهتمام بهم
وسيبذلون أي جهد  يمكننا
الوصول إليهم بأمان وبحكمة
[موسيقى]